welcome to another edition of between
two ferns and my guest today is my
people Cara hey you're gonna be here say
of all the things you can win an Oscar
for how surprised are you that you won
one for acting here we go
I noticed that you're wearing a shirt is
everything okay
and you have a major league in here I'm
so I'm so sorry don't do that
[Music]
you killed Matthew McConaughey he's dead
he's brought back to life he was
momentarily dead you owe me
go across the country get ten more
episodes of between two first ten your
dumb internet talk show and you give me
a network culture I'm a white man and
I'm straight I deserve it green as ever
is the width off to you we're taken
between two ferns on the road my guest
today is Benedict Cumberbatch but
[Music]
Benedict can benefit Lumberjacks Giada
Benedict Cumberbatch that's what it is I
read online that you're a very private
and declined to answer questions that
make you feel uncomfortable
is that true and how old were you when
you got your first period
Bradley Cooper co-wrote directed and
starred in a star is born
I hear it's great are you hoping that
will open doors for other hot idiots
I don't know if I'm gonna get these
shows out we don't have any money we're
hungry we're gonna order at the clam
strips how big are they have you ever
seen a chicken strip I've never seen a
chicken wearing clothes
here's to the crazy ones
the misfits ending docks I'm just
curious about the pathology behind this
some people would say we're the crazy
ones but I think Richelieu I love your
show
what if we take this upstairs he's
probably at home polishing his he got is
that what he calls his penis between two
ferns the movie is this bit of e it is
it gonna be in theaters not in theaters
not in theaters
you